algumas pessoas que brilham naturalmente
de falso benéfico sem esforço
[Música]
mas o que eu quero conversar com você
fez um assunto que é muito importante a
fertilidade
talvez alguns de vocês só de ouvir falar
essa palavra vencer pelo visto essa
conversa não é pra mim então eu vou indo
nessa tchau
essa conversa é pra você se essa
conversa para todo mundo porque
fertilidade importa pra todos nós
fertilidade importa para aqueles de nós
que já tem o que querem ter filhos
fertilidade importa que aqueles que não
querem ter filhos agora ou no futuro
fertilidade importa para todos nós
porque sem ela nós nem estaríamos aqui
ea fertilidade importa porque ela faz
parte da nossa saúde
agora vamos fazer aqui um exercício de
imaginação
imaginem que as pessoas não precisam
mais sente medo dúvida vergonha em
relação as tais duas partes íntimas
ao invés disso elas conhecem o próprio
corpo
entender a própria fertilidade
imagine que a menstruação não deixam as
mulheres desesperadas e nem pega hoje
surpresa ao invés disso existe uma forma
segura e confiável para as mulheres
saberem quando vem a próxima menstruação
imagine que as pessoas que querem
engravidar não precisam ficar tentado
várias vezes atirando no escuro e
sofrendo com a frustração ao invés disso
elas também sabem como funciona o
próprio corpo
ela sabe quando é o período fértil do
ciclo menstrual
então elas sabem quando é o melhor
momento para tentar engravidar
imaginem que as pessoas que não querem
engravidar não precisam ficar sempre com
medo de uma gravidez indesejada
ao invés disso elas também sabem quando
o período fértil do ciclo menstrual que
elas usam esse conhecimento em seu
benefício
tá bom
parece interessante mas eu não curto
muito esse negócio de ficar imaginando
eu prefiro ficar com os meus dois pés
bem fincados na realidade
tá bom você não precisa imaginar tudo
isso já é possível
e tem nome percepção da fertilidade
percepção da fertilidade é conhecimento
conhecimento sobre o próprio corpo
o conhecimento sobre como a fertilidade
funciona para homens e para mulheres
conhecimento sobre como a fertilidade
faz parte da nossa saúde homens em geral
são itens desde a adolescência até o fim
da vida
durante esse tempo eles produzem
espermatozóides
o tempo inteiro todos os dias 24 horas
por dia sete dias por semana
já as mulheres são certas
desde a adolescência até a menopausa
durante esse período se elas não usam
nenhum tipo de contraceptivo com
hormônios
elas têm ciclos menstruais e o óvulo só
fica disponível
alguns dias por ciclo
tá bom dia quais dias são esses
é aqui que entram os métodos de
percepção da fertilidade métodos de
percepção da fertilidade são formas de
observar e registrar que interpretar os
sinais de fertilidade do corpo da mulher
e sinais de fertilidade são como
sintomas
eles mostram do lado de fora o que
acontece dentro do corpo durante o ciclo
menstrual
tá bom então dá pra checar os sinais de
fertilidade
usando esses métodos de percepção da
fertilidade mas para isso a gente não
precisa de laboratório técnicos
especializados equipamentos caríssimos
de última geração
eu trouxe aqui pra mostrar pra vocês
dois desses equipamentos papel higiênico
que termômetro equipamentos caríssimos
de última geração
o papel higiênico serve para checar um
dos sinais de fertilidade que eu fui de
cervical
fui cervical é um fluido natural e
saudável que é produzido pelo colo do
útero e que muda em quantidade cor e
textura ao longo do ciclo menstrual
isso indica que a população está próxima
prestes a acontecer ou já aconteceu
naquele seco
o termo serve para checar outro sinal de
fertilidade que a temperatura basal a
temperatura basal é a temperatura do
nosso corpo medida em estado de repouso
logo depois que a gente levanta depois
que a gente acorda mas antes de se
levantar
ela também muda ao longo do ciclo
isso indica que a população ainda não
aconteceu ou já aconteceu com esses dois
sinais de fertilidade é possível
determinar o período fértil
o ciclo menstrual e saber quando vem a
próxima menstruação
esses métodos de percepção da
fertilidade são baseados em décadas de
pesquisa científica e quando eles são
ensinados corretamente são formas
seguras e eficazes para engravidar
ele está em grave da monitor atual de
saúde
tá bom carol interessante
ninguém vai perder esse daí capaz bom
tem outra coisa que é difícil dirigir
quem dirige tem que prestar atenção ao
mesmo tempo no painel do carro que
indica as condições do carro do
motorista assim como os sinais de
fertilidade
o volante na marcha nos pedais
retrovisor espelho carros ônibus motos
ciclista pedestre é cachorro correndo no
meio da rua
é difícil mas ainda assim é
perfeitamente possível aprender a
dirigir
então da mesma forma que é possível
estudar o básico sobre o funcionamento
de um carro e sobre as leis de trânsito
e praticar para poder dirigir de forma
responsável e segura é possível estudar
o básico sobre o funcionamento do nosso
corpo para poder usar os métodos de
percepção da fertilidade de forma
responsável e segura
ok talvez agora vocês estejam pensando
mais ou menos o mesmo que eu pensei dois
anos atrás é que eu nunca ouvi falar
disso antes
bom hoje privilégio de ter acesso a
serviços de saúde educação de boa
qualidade de estudar biologia aqui na
federal
durante a graduação diz a biologia no
mestrado que trabalhar com biologia mas
eu só fui aprender sobre a percepção da
fertilidade aos 27 anos e fiquei
conformada mas também curiosa e comecei
a investigar artigos científicos livros
sites o que encontrava sua percepção da
fertilidade fui demorando mas é óbvio
que não fiquei obcecada com isso tá de
pé e deixar claro eu sou uma pessoa
muito calma o que eu descobri é que
existem algumas barreiras barreiras que
impedem esse conhecimento da percepção
da fertilidade e chegar até as pessoas
uma dessas barreiras é a confusão em um
primeiro momento é fácil de confundir os
métodos de percepção da fertilidade com
os métodos de calendário entre eles a
famosa tabelinha esses dois conjuntos de
métodos têm o mesmo objetivo que é
terminar o período fértil do ciclo
menstrual e determinar quando vai ser a
próxima extração mas eles fazem isso de
forma diferente os métodos de calendário
são baseados em registrar a duração dos
ciclos menstruais passados e fazer um
cálculo para tentar determinar quando
foi alvo ação que a partir daí estimar
quando vai ser a próxima a ovulação
isso é olhar o passado e tentar entender
como vai ser o futuro e é útil para dar
uma certa noção os dias
o estado não é muito confiável já os
métodos de percepção da fertilidade a
forma que eles funcionam é o seu observa
registra e interpreta os sinais de
fertilidade dia a dia você olha para o
presente pra entender o que está
acontecendo aqui
agora no presente o resultado é bem mais
confiável uma ótima barreira que impede
a percepção da fertilidade de chegar até
as pessoas
é o idioma
a maior parte das informações das fontes
de informação sobre a percepção da
fertilidade em inglês
mas há um português isso tudo estimulou
a começar um blog para compartilhar
essas informações sobre a percepção da
fertilidade em português e tentar fazer
com que esse conhecimento pudesse chegar
a mais pessoas e as respostas que tem
recebido desde então são muito
interessantes com frases do tipo
isso mudou a forma de enxergar o meu
próprio corpo
eu pretendo ensinar isso pros meus
filhos
lima que foi muito interessante porque a
pessoa escreveu tudo em maiúsculas
porque a gente não aprende na escola que
a gente pode parar e pensar que a gente
pudesse aprender desde cedo a percepção
da fertilidade como seria
algumas pessoas têm medo disso
acho que se a gente conversar ensinar
saúde sexual e reprodutiva para os
jovens
vai ser um caos a que eles vão iniciar a
vida sexual mais cedo porque eles vão
ter doenças sexualmente transmissíveis
que os casos de gravidez indesejada vai
aumentar mas na verdade é o contrário
que acontece quando a gente não ensina
a saúde sexual e reprodutiva quando a
gente não conversa abertamente sobre
esses assuntos
quando a informação não chega até as
pessoas quando ela chega a torcida
é aí que o caos reina
se a gente pudesse aprender a percepção
da fertilidade
desde cedo e só abriria portas só
abriria portas para mais informação as
pessoas poderem atingir seus objetivos
seus desejos ter filhos ou não ter
filhos mas entendimento e aceitação e
respeito ao próprio corpo
mais saúde percepção da fertilidade é
conhecimento do próprio corpo
é uma idéia que merece e precisa ser
compartilhada
afinal de contas tem uma frase que diz
conhecimento é poder
[Aplausos]